[Music]
we're going to try something adam we
didn't know you were coming up we were
like yeah not this one we want a normal
conversation
we like you too much let's try doing
just three sentence answers and then as
soon as you popped up we're like
right um i i say thank you um i want to
start with how much i often loved this
movie it is
fantastic i can't i could give you a
million adjectives but i have a million
questions um one of the many things that
i love about the film and the book is
that it's loaded with powerful women
which was highly unusual back in the 60s
when frank wrote the book can you sort
of talk about that aspect of the
film yeah i mean i i think i i loved
having these conversations with denny
obviously because he has been so merged
into the world of june since he was 14
and also being the man he is of 2021
knowing what the quality is and knowing
where he wants to get to
we keep on saying that frank was ahead
of his time in the 60s which he was you
know when you read the book there's so
much detail into placing women in
empowerment and i mean let's just start
talking about the benedicerate you know
just
that in itself at the same time it's
it's not equality is it i mean and that
is the story as well we need to create
the shifts of dynamic and and have a
hierarchical setting to create the
sort of the pressure points of when
she's allowed to step into a room and
the dynamic between our characters
um so it's a balance we can't become too
pc
and we need to be true to a story that
was written in the 60s
um but i think we balanced it quite well
yeah it's way more than three sentences
that was a lot of sentences but we're
not doing that now oh yeah sorry i
forgot
um
there's so many things to love in this
movie but i am curious when you were
talking to your friends and family what
were the things that you kept raving
about regarding this film
all of it i mean yeah really all of it i
i want to say the sets the the
photography the
you know the kind of brutalist
architecture and the lighting like what
greg did as well
the performances
you know
certain performances
um
but no i think for me it was just like
denis you know being able to be
near a visionary like that and to get to
know him even better and to just see him
creating
with so much passion
that was really you know what i love i
love when you sit down with someone and
actors or fellow
lovers for film and they go
demi
and i kind of go i know
you know that's kind of enough it's it's
don't even know if you know
oh completely uh my last question for
you i i love believe me i love denise um
when i
uh i love learning about the stuff that
you don't read in press notes and what
you might not know what do you think
might surprise fans of this or soon to
be fans of this film about the making of
the movie
i mean i think it's
i'm gonna say that divided into two but
i think i don't know i i think maybe the
sense of
exploration of themes of the book that
are not as literal as maybe you'd you
know one would think
uh
distilling
many various elements that are in the
book but finding an economical way to
like distill all those things into maybe
one scene or one line and still having
it somehow
give you the punch that you had when you
read that chapter in the book and yet it
just comes out in these two these two
words exchanges but you're like that's
still how i imagined it that's what i
saw that's what i felt when i read that
thing and um yeah i think that there's
that's something that happened that i
completely agree with and i think i've
had we've had audiences come up to us
and say
this is how i saw my my dune this is how
i read it
um i mean then he's done something
something that
tickles the readers yeah he made what's
called a masterpiece um anyway i gotta
go thank you so much for your time uh
and good luck with the rest of your
speed dating
thank you thank you